هؤلاء الطلاب في موسكو يدرسون لغه
المندرين ساهم التقارب الجديد بين الصين
وروسيا بزياده اعداد الطلاب المسجلين في
هذه المدرسه الخاصه اصحابها ياملون بزياده
عدد الدارسين للغه الصينيه مع زياره
الرئيس الصيني لموسكو اعتقد ان العلاقات
بين روسيا والصين ستتكثف بشكل اكبر فنحن
جيران جيدون هناك تعبير يقول اذا بقيت
روسيا والصين معا فلن يتمكن احد من التغلب
عليهما على قائمه المواضيع في الزياره
الرسميه لثلاثه ايام الحرب في اوكرانيا
الصين لم تندد بالغزو الروسي لكنها اقترحت
وثيقه لوضع حد للنزاع واقامه السلام بكين
وموسكو تتشاركان الرغبه بتقليل النفوذ
الغربي على النظام العالمي خاصه النفوذ
الذي تمليه الولايات المتحده التعاون
الاقتصادي المتنامي بين البلدين هو الملف
الثاني على الطاوله روسيا التي عزلتها
العقوبات فزادت من تعاملات الاقتصاديه مع
جارتها الصينيه وصل حجم التبادل بينهما
الى 190 مليار دولار عام 2022 لكن من جهه
اخرى لا يمكن للشركات الصينيه التخلي عن
السوق الغربيه هل الصين مستعده للتضحيه
بقدرتها على التجاره مع الغرب لبناء دورها
كلاعب دولي مسؤول هل هي مستعده للتضحيه
بكل شيء للدفاع عن موسكو حتى الان لا يبدو
من الواضح على الاطلاق انها مستعده للقيام
بهذه التضحيه
بموقفها القريب من موسكو مقابل كيف تحاول
بكين موازنه القوى في هذا الصراع تم اتهام
الصين بمحاوله ارسال اسلحه لروسيا لكنها
كذبت هذه الاتهامات مع تعيينغ للمره
الثالثه كزعيم للصين يريد هذه المره تقديم
نفسه كوسيط دوليا اساسي